vous allez voir un bretagne ça fait
toujours un effet war
bienvenue à kerzellec attention à la
tête vous dormez dans la chambre de mme
amy soizic elle est née ici l'ailier
même morte
cegid est complètement c'était terrible
là
[Musique]
oh
[ __ ]
ne vous inquiétez pas c'est la bretagne
a toujours plein de trucs à faire la
palourde se situe à la limite du sable
sec mais appréciable c'est qu'ici les
mouiller et au sable
et à la taille tu sais quoi maintenant
je me suis inscrite à un cours de
sculpture
tu travailles toujours pas à quoi je me
suis fait piquer par une guêpe une gaffe
en bretagne vise à crouy ramène tina
elle a un cousin qui s'est fait piquer
au parti comme toi il a gonflé gonflé
gonflé et il est mort merci jean miche
jettou météo de merde on va passer notre
temps à picoler comme pendant le
confinement soleil devrait venir plus
souvent parce que de lyon c'est qu'à
peine 7 heures porte à porte est gentil
on a mis plus de huit heures ah bah ça
c'est parce que t'as pas su immobilière
que je vous ai envoyés au nigeria 6 mois
moi je vais envoyer sur votre groupe
ou la cua lo troupe bâtisse c'est un
terreau panneaux et là vous allez me
d'engrais
[Musique]
ok li na waie belge en est à préciser on
s'y tient
elle allie la beauté c'est la mort
c'était quoi dans la lah - le tsl
mouettes ah oui on va cesser le symbole
de la mouette tout mayol non
et vous savez quoi apéro il est 16h
mouchel et 16h [ __ ] ça avance pas ses
vacances
[Musique]